In Muslim, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam instructed the companions
that even if the forah is called, do not
stand for salah until you see me that I
have come out into the masid. So the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam
prohibited the companions
from standing and preparing their rose
before the before the imam comes out.
Now we have our salah timed which means
at a particular time the is called at a
particular time the imam is present.
However,
in the form of
the scholars agree
that standing for salah and standing in
the row for prayer should never happen
before the
differ on which part of the. So for
instance in the mab of
it is that a person stands at
in the imal the people stand at
used to stand at
but all agree that it is incorrect to
stand for the prayer and make a row
before the is called before the imam
comes out for a number of reasons but
one of those reasons is so that it is
does not distract and deter from the
worship that should be taking place
before the
what is the worship that should be
taking place before the
dua is dua the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us that between
and there is a dua that Allah will
answer.
Another thing is if the imam has
something that occurs let's say I'm here
we all stand up for salah the is called
and then I remember I don't have to
wudoo I have to make wudoo this happens
this happened to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam as a matter of fact it
happened that he forgot he had to make
what is the sunnah is the sunnah
take my place I don't want to keep
people no the sunnah is wait. He went
and bathed and came back. And so for
this reason, it is incorrect. It is a
mistake to stand for salah and to begin
making rows before the is called before
the im is present because the im
dictates when the salah takes place not
the
this is why the scholars say
the is to the discretion of the he's in
charge of that
but the that is always to the discretion
of the im salah doesn't start until the
imam is present and so this is an
important thing we here have a big
responsibility what is our
responsibility that collectively we
don't do anything officially that is not
the sunnah somebody walks in and sees
they say that's a good idea we should
try that over in our masid
not knowing that this is not the sunnah,
this is against the sunnah. We never
want to adopt anything officially
without it being something from the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's sunnah.
So we wait until the is called to stand
for salah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the chapters of
the chapters of
bathing. And when a person is obligated
to bathe, what states of being or what
occasions
make bathing an obligation?
Not just make bathing a time
something that is ideal. We're speaking
about obligatory.
What is binding? The author here
mentions five instances.
Five instances in which it is
obligatory. It is binding upon a person
to bathe. Now the first of those is el
janaba.
El janaba is a state of sexual impurity.
And we mentioned that el janaza el
janaza el janaba is
after
there is a sexual climax
that results in the expulsion of semen
or sexual secretions.
This is what we call el janeneva and it
could happen to a person while they are
asleep. It could happen to a person
while they are awake.
And the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam mentions that El Janab
is the first and most prominent
the mo the first and the most
prominent and the principle
state of being that demands that a
person or requires that a person make
that a person bathe. Now what is the
bare minimum of? This is something that
we will discuss inshallah in the next
chapter when we discuss the
description of first we're going to
discuss when is obligatory and then we
follow that up with what the bare
minimum or what the pillars of are. And
so the author mentions janaba
janab
as the prophet sallall.ai Wasallam says
[Silence]
she is the the mother of Malik and is
one of the most prominent
u
women of the companions.
When the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
arrived at Medina,
she met him at
Wad is the area in Medina that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam arrived at.
She met him there with an entourage, a
group of the Muslim that were waiting
for him. Every day they would go out and
wait for him there until the sun got
high. And
when he finally arrived, she had a
little boy with her, 10-year-old boy.
And as he was being welcomed in and
ushered in, she came to him and she
said, "This is Enis. This is my son.
Please take him as a servant for you.
Take him in as your servant." And so the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam accepted.
And so Annis continued to be his
servant. What does that mean? His
servant. He'd get his water. He bring
his shoes. He would do any odds or
ends that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam needed etc.
And so, and because he was a little boy,
but he was a very smart young young man,
he was able to be in the more intimate
aspects of the prophet's life.
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam because he
was still under the age of puberty at
the beginning, he was able to come into
his houses and talk to his wives and
witness a lot of things that older
companions were unable to do. And so
this is just one of her hassat.
Another of her hassat is that the great
companion Abu Tala
which would be Anisb Malik's stepfather
because Malik the father of Annis.
It's a difference of opinion as to what
occurred with him. Some say he passed
away. Others say he died as a
disbeliever. Others say that he became
Muslim. And all of those are inauthentic
narrations,
but he was not around. And so Abu Talha
was an ibn Malik's stepfather, but he
wanted to marry Omul. And Abu Talha was
a very very wealthy man. And so
as it is customary, he told her to ask
for whatever
whatever dowy, whatever m she wanted. He
could he could he could do it because he
was a very wealthy man. His wealth in
our terms is multi multi-millionaire.
Very very wealthy.
And so she asked him for her dowy. Does
anybody know what she required as her
dowy was a very high price
[Arabic recitation]
dowy. And so to to her dowy was that he
accept Islam
something that no amount of money can
buy. And so he accepted Islam. He
married
and became one of the foremost
companions of the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam. A man meets a
righteous woman, she can make everything
in his life better. Right? This guy got
the best of this life and the hereafter
because he happened to come upon a
righteous woman.
On the other hand,
you meet
a woman that is not righteous and good
God, you will have quite a time. A
woman, a good woman can make your life
good. A bad woman can break your life.
And this is why Ibraimisam
made this one of the most important
parts and the important messages to his
son, right? when he came to Mecca to
find his son and he had married a woman
and
is
out
hunting
but he found Ismael's wife and he didn't
say that he was Ibraim the father of is
he was just a traveler looking for is
and she said come in
and she gave him as is customary marry
for it's an old man
and he said how is your life with this
mah she said it's terrible we are just
we are struggling financially
etc etc etc she doesn't know this man
from Adam but she airs out her husband's
her husband's not secrets but her
husband's
you know, hardships.
And so he said, "Well, I'm it's best I
be going tell Is when he comes back to
change the
porch, to change his stoop." A stoop is
the first part of the house that
you enter into. Sometimes this is
translated as doormat. This is a wrong
translation.
Is the first part of the floor of a
person's house.
And so is came back. She said, "This old
man came by and he said, "Did did he say
anything? Did you leave me a message?"
She said, "Yes." She said, "He told me
to tell you a salam and to change the
stoop of your house, of your front
door." He said, "That was my father and
he's instructed me to divorce you.
You're divorced."
Why? That's all that's all I needed to
know.
Right now, we are not as
insightful as I am.
Ibraimisam was a messenger of Allah
and was a prophet of Allah. But the
point of this story that the prophet
tells us is to articulate
the dire nature
of the woman in the household. The woman
of the household is incredibly
important. Is
the neutron
more important than the proton in an
atom?
We can't say that they're more important
or less important. They don't exist
without each other. Correct? And this is
the nature that the husband and the wife
share in the house. So, Ibraimisam
wanted to make sure that this happened
before they had children.
and the story is long and well known.
Maybe one time we will give that. Give
it in a hutbah. You think I'll make it
out of here alive if I give a hutba on
that? You think so? Will you protect me?
We'll have to hire we'll have to hire
armed security to get me out of the
masid after I give that. Yeah. This is
this is prohibited speech. I'm not I am
I you, but you're treading on thin
ice, right?
So the point is is that
she said to the messenger,
"Oh messenger of Allah,"
and we mentioned this narration
yesterday.
And so Bkari Muslim Sal
is the prophet's wife,
the wife of the late Abu Sal, the widow
we should say of the late Abu Salah
she narrates that
which is an Malik's mother asked the
messenger of Allah saiam
she
she set this up with a
with a statement. She said, "Oh
messenger of Allah, indeed Allah is
never too shy for the truth or modest
for the truth." And so is there an
obligation of bathing upon a woman if
she has a wet dream? Because often wet
dream is associated what? usually with
men because it's most prominent in
males.
And he said yes if she finds the traces
of the sexual secretions
from said wet dream. And that goes for
men and women. Person has a dream. It's
a sexual dream. A dream of a of sexual
nature. Even if they feel whatever they
feel in their dream, no matter how vivid
the dream was, if the person wakes up
and checks his or her clothing, if there
is
you know the result of that, if there
is wetness from that, then the person
makes
if not then the person does not need to
make. And the opposite is correct. If a
person wakes up, they do not remember
having a wet dream, but they find the
evidence of a wet dream, then is
obligatory. They are in a state of
janaba.